du rififi à montfermeil dans la région
parisienne l'histoire d'un maire qui ne
supporte pas que deux directrices
d'école maternelle et inscrit une
quarantaine d'enfants immigrés
l'histoire racontée par marie-claire
tiers le 4 octobre le maire de
montfermeil envoie une lettre à deux
directrices d'école maternelle qui n'ont
pas voulu suivre ses directives et on
scolarité scolarisés une quarantaine
d'enfants immigrés dans cette lettre le
maire exclu le rétablissement des
services publics de la ville or depuis
1982 avec la loi de décentralisation ce
sont les communes qui financent les
écoles maternelles équipements quand
nous scolaire et cetera sauf les
salaires
toutefois le ministère de l'éducation
nationale rappelle que le préfet peut
aussi se substituer à l'autorité
municipale pas simplement un problème
d'immigration ça commence comme ça mais
au fait c'est un chat au ces ce coût
local ce maire c'est à dire qu'en fin de
compte il ne supporte pas que les
directeurs d'écoles puisse faire des
choses sur ordre du préfet du ministre
de l'éducation nationale sans vous avoir
le droit de lui demander l'autorisation
dès qu'on bouge un petit doigt il veut
que l'éducation nationale soit sa botte
or on regrette nous on ne dépend pas de
lui on dépend du ministre